good morning joining us
um what support can you offer them
I think we continue the support that
we've been giving and uh the Prime
Minister has was foreign secretary
beforehand working in step with our
defense secretary Ben Wallace and at the
time prime minister Boris Johnson and we
continue to do that and we need to make
sure that the West is also resolved to
making sure that Putin must fail and the
people of Ukraine must succeed okay so
is there anything specific that we can
do to help them given these missile
strikes that we have seen over the last
couple of nights well of course some of
these operational matters of the direct
support will be given will be held
discussed confidentially confidentially
with uh both within government but also
with the Ukrainian president and I know
that we have always stepped up to
deliver what we can but this is a time
for other countries to continue the
level of support that they've been
showing and where necessary to escalate
their their level of support directly to
the Ukrainian Armed Forces as we have
done okay this is our first opportunity
to chat since the conference and there
has been a further slump in the polls
how are you going to get back on track
well I'm very conscious that we've set
out a plan for growth there's a whole uh
continuing of different policy uh
improvements to try and help and lock
our growth challenges that we've been
facing and indeed the chancellor
announced yesterday he's brought forward
the median term fiscal plan for the 31st
of October
chosen to do that recognizing that we
wanted to get on and show how our plans
and make sure people have confidence
that they can get on and start
delivering them and he's decided that
we're in a position where we can bring
that forward it's not because the
Market's getting jittery again not to my
knowledge
um I think it's about doing a lot of
work at PACE uh understandably uh but I
think he decided that we're in a good
State and we'll continue to discuss this
across government and indeed with
parliamentary colleagues
um over the few weeks ahead you say in a
good state but the director of The
Institute for fiscal studies is saying
this morning that there's a 60 billion
pound Black Hole uh in your figures and
that's either going to be done to sort
it out with a hatchet to public spending
or the equivalent of a Tempe increase in
the basic rate of tax which one well I
think the ifs obviously does its own
modeling the government works with the
bank of England and the obr on these
measures and that's uh What uh treasury
has been working on and doing different
discussions with different departments
but I think the ifs also pointed out if
we don't grow then this problem will get
worse and worse and that's why very
clearly the Prime Minister and
chancellor set out a plan for growth uh
a lot of that of course was the
important element of giving Assurance to
household and to businesses about what
support they would get on energy costs
much of which is not in the direct
control of people we've already seen an
impact in the reduction of inflation uh
forecasts just from the measures that
we've taken but to consider we've had
this Aftershock of covid we're still not
quite yet got the global supply chain
going again and we still have these huge
problems on energy security which is
affecting not just this hasn't been
affecting just this country but of
course also countries right across
Europe and elsewhere in the world but
people should be assured we have the
second lowest debt to GDP ratio in the G
UH 60 billion pound black hole though um
how are you going well I'm I'm just uh
flagging that ifs has come up with its
own modeling is it right and the chance
that's uh not for me to say that's their
forecasts uh the chancellor will be
speaking at the end of the month uh with
the medium-term fiscal plan okay but
suggestions are that you will have to
find on their figures for now we'll hear
yours as you say by the end of the month
if you don't
um fix these figures with an increase in
basic rate of income tax you'll need to
reduce the budget of every Department
except the NHS and defense by 15 is
there that much fat to get rid of well
I'm just not going to get into
hypotheticals k um the chancellor is
working on that uh with uh as the
aspects the obr other departments right
now to go through um but I the
government is united we have to get
growth otherwise uh and that will help
us to fund our public sectors in the
future as well okay and so you're not
going to get into figures we'll just
have to wait and see till the 31st of
October as I said the Market's getting
jittery again one wonders what they
might do between now and then what we do
know is that Santander are saying that
they're setting um just looking at the
exact quote from their boss saying
they're having to set aside more money
for defaults uh because they think that
people are just not going to be able to
afford their mortgages going forward how
do you reassure them otherwise well the
bank of England sets the interest rates
for the country and it's for their
projection to decide they we've had
historically low interest rates for many
years now and of course they're going
through covert there was a lot of work
done when many people either weren't uh
were benefiting from furlough or indeed
were not who had to be helped with that
I'm just flagging That Was Then That Was
Then historically what the government
did to help people Bank of England the
bank of England sets the interest rates
so it'll be what responsibility should
this government take well the backing of
England sets interest rates um I'm not
aware that any other commentator once
the government to start setting interest
rates again
um and I doubt uh Santander does as well
but the sorts of policies that we've
shown like our support to both
households and businesses in substantial
energy package building on the 37
billion pounds that we had already
talking about buildings you're talking
about ditching home targets for
affordable homes why are you doing that
I'm not aware of any of that that isn't
true I'm not that isn't true that
apparently ministers have drawn up plans
to exempt developers from having to
build affordable homes to scrap
Environmental Protections and to allow
people to add extensions without
permission that according to Simon Clark
that's not right I'm not aware of that
uh policy but uh if you want to ask
Simon Clark about policies I guess the
Deputy Prime Minister with all due
respect
um well you're just throwing comments at
me okay
um I'm not aware of there's not
something that's been discussed around
I'm not aware of uh specific things like
that no okay how interesting Amazon
Secretary of State for health and that's
uh I have come on today to talk about
what we're doing to help tackle the
backlogs and I'm pleased to be
announcing a further 10 Community
diagnostic Centers to be opened I'm
actually opening one formally today in
London but places in Burnley uh places
in uh merseyside uh places in the Isle
of Wight will be getting a diagnostic
center because we know getting on and
delivering for patients is really
important and those Diagnostics are a
key part of making sure whether we know
if people need treatment or not and that
is one of the critical backlogs that we
need to get fixed
um also talking about National Insurance
rise being scrapped today in Parliament
that's at 36 billion pounds over three
years that will be gone how will you
protect the NHS given that that money
was going to be spent on the NHS and
social care well that was going to be in
effect a hypothecated levy that was set
aside the Prime Minister said clearly
during her leadership campaign she
didn't think it was right to put up
taxes and so so this will be funded more
generally from General taxation rather
than specific levies so it's the funding
is still there in order to make sure
both social care and health system
particularly that money was intended in
the health system for tackling backlogs
that we spend that and then moving on to
aspects of social care of which we'll be
doing the first down payment this winter
with 500 million pounds to be allocated
across the country nurses balloting to
strike for the first time in 106 years
also relevant to your department what
are you going to do about that well I
understand
um that the ballot is now open uh we
have honored the independent pay review
bodies recommendations on this uh and uh
that was a higher than many of the other
pay Rises that other public sector
workers are getting and I'm confident
um that uh those uh elements will
continue to
do I say it's uh having respected the
independent pay review body I'm not
anticipating that we'll be making any
further changes okay so it looks as
though it'll have a strike on your hands
well I think that's a decision for the
nurses who decide how to vote this um
this uh in this next coming month okay I
mean you're sitting here as the Deputy
Prime Minister this morning nurses
threatening to strike for the first time
in 106 years the head of Santander
saying he's having to put extra money
aside because he thinks that people are
going to default on their mortgages The
Institute for fiscal studies saying
there's a 60 billion pound black hole in
your figures
um and you just think the country will
just carry on running as it is well no
we need to change that's why we need a
plan for growth and why we have a plan
but I've asked you for it and it's well
that was set out a few weeks ago and
then the medium-term fiscal plan is what
the chancellor will be saying at the end
of the month so it's not exactly
business as usual that's why in my role
as Secretary of State for Health and
Social care we've got real focus on ABCD
the ambulances backlogs I'm talking
about today as well as some of the
things that we'll be doing in terms of
care including the discharge fund for
this winter so we'll continue to try and
make progress in delivering for patients
and indeed delivering right across the
country including the delivery of the
energy cost package where we are
supporting homes and indeed our
businesses you talk about the ABCD plan
which we've heard a lot about both from
you from the Prime Minister also from
Nadeem zahari who spoke about it too
what can we expect on the Tobacco
Control plan
well I'm focused at the moment on the
ABCD there's a whole number of different
prevention strategies which are already
underway and some are being considered
uh my immediate Focus has been ABCD
about we've created within the NHS local
NHS boards they're referred to as
integrated care system boards Air Care
Systems which have a board and that's
where I'm intending to put all of our
effort and focus on how we get that
local Health and Social care system
really working together so that's that's
where I'm putting a lot of my focus
right now okay the plan was vital we
were told to help the government realize
its ambition of becoming smoke free by
2030 we heard that from Sajid Javid
reducing number of 15 year olds who
smoke from eight to three percent
reducing smoking adults in England from
15 and a half to 12 reducing inequality
Gap in smoking prevalence end of 2022
was the target has that Target been
scrapped I I'm not aware any Targets has
been scrapped um but I'm going to go
ahead then I'm not aware any Target
that's been scrapped my focus right now
is the ABCD there's quite a lot of
prevention programs already underway and
I'll be of course looking at many more
these in detail there's quite a lot of
ambition that we have uh looking at say
at the Cancer plan again we're going
through that carefully and my
expectation is the prime minister set
out is we'll publish that by the end of
the year
um okay my producer's just talking to me
in my ear as I'm talking to you so she
if she could just take me again I think
it's something from the bank of England
bear with me there's a warning I'm being
told from the bank of England
and apparently there's an ongoing route
in the guilts market a material risk in
UK Financial stability thoughts on that
well it's news to me as well and uh I
suggest that you're the Deputy Prime
Minister you have to have views on these
things I've just been sat here for the
last 10 15 minutes you're not expecting
it uh it's a matter of dare I say for
the chancellor I'm sure that you can
follow up with the chancellor today uh
the bank is saying that it's going to
have to bolster its emergency Bond uh
buying plan well the banker of England
is the responsible organization uh and
uh it's for them and the chancellor to
work together on this matter that's good
to talk to you as always thank you very
much